in five four three two one I told you we
get right into this [ __ ]
welcome everybody to another episode of
the genius brain podcast we have a very
very special guest
introduce yourself [ __ ] I'm DEA I'm
Meg we are Megan dia we are sisters
because someone thought we were a couple
yesterday oh really
does it happen often no that was the
first time this guy came up to me we
were playing a so far sound show which
is like a house show basically and he
just said how long have you guys been
together but you guys look related
though I think so yeah oh do you think
that that's so [ __ ] funny that was
his fantasy I shouldn't mess with him a
little bit but it would it would have
gotten weird for me you should like
we're looking for a third partner
actually you look ready just the part so
you you're you're doing music again huh
yeah so Meg and I split up
um our last record was eight years ago I
think and then yeah so we just released
a new record in July called happy sad
and it's been a long time we went
through a lot you know it's interesting
cuz I knew of you guys from because I
didn't listen to that genre of music but
there was people in my school that did
and then they listened to you guys a lot
I actually met you before way back in
the day you actually performed to your
is such a bad mood that day it was very
understandable because you performed it
was it was in deep downtown LA and it
was right after my buddies the
stereotypes came up do you remember this
no they blew out the [ __ ] speakers
and then you had to perform after and
your speakers and the speaker's didn't
[ __ ] work and so when you were going
up couldn't hear you for [ __ ] do you
remember this
no traumatising that I just blocked it
out of my mind
stop dude you were so [ __ ] mad and I
was like how do you everybody get the
[ __ ] out of her way no because you they
literally perform and you know this [ __ ]
was like hip-hop music great so that
[ __ ] busted up the speakers it was bad
like it was just [ __ ] and then when
you came up your nobody could hear your
vocals oh wow yeah and then
sorry y'all not the stage I was like
although she has hate in her heart right
now like everybody get the [ __ ] out of
the way dude you're so [ __ ] mad I was
like this was gonna kill somebody cause
it sounds about right yeah I feel like
now I've adapted more of a well okay
whatever it's like you got paid I just
bought okay get the [ __ ] out of there so
why'd you guys start to do music again
because you went into acting and well so
let's see okay let's go back track so
you guys split up and why'd you guys
split at the time we were so we had been
playing music for six or seven years at
that point started playing music before
we were 21 you know so we were together
for a long time and we had indie labels
we had gone on to major label we had
toured all over the world at that point
and we just started getting a little
jaded and unappreciative of each other
and weren't being very kind to each
other and this is yeah just got over it
got over the band thought that we were
better off separate and wanted to do
something else and then dia got the
voice gig and for a while we were
blaming it on that like you got this TV
show and so we're done but I think it
would have been done it was unraveling
before that happened oh really
mm-hmm that's so interesting because I
always try to wonder with family
dynamics right
because you already have your personal
family relationship first right and then
you have this other side where you guys
had to be performers I find that so hard
- because I don't know if I could ever
do that with my brother right like if my
brother could perform or whatever he was
a comic I don't think we could be a duo
comic I think I'd [ __ ] kill him you
know so how did how did you guys balance
that [ __ ] out for those six or seven
years because things get personal like
it's it's impossible for not to get
personal yeah it's really hard we've had
a lot of times where we just did not
talk to each other yeah we're not really
hostile people though we never got on
each other's faces but it was kind of
just more of that awkward you know we
know each other so well but all of a
sudden we'd be at Christmas dinner and
all of our other scissors would leave
and it was kind of just us and it it was
to the point where we almost didn't know
each other anymore it was like so um
how's acting how's LA
cool good the weather is pretty hot
there is it cold in Utah yeah cool
skiing well bye I'm gonna go get more
food it just got so weird yeah it was
uncomfortable at the end I think in the
beginning when we first started we had
this common goal in mind and it was new
and exciting and so we were able to keep
our personal stuff out of the way but I
think over time especially when you're
going through your late 20s the band
became such a part of at least my
identity yeah my ego and I am Megan dia
and this is all I know to be me is just
playing music in this band and so if
anything started to get in my way or it
just was such a huge hit to me you know
yeah so I think our egos became more
fragile the older we get the more Megan
dia tied into who we were I think
there's probably a lot of fear involved
in that ya know cuz that's after year
guys is like career started to skyrocket
and cuz it's weird because like I said
like I grew up in a predominantly just
you know black Asian Mexican
neighborhood and if I if I heard of you
guys that media if anything cuz I don't
know any music outside of hip-hop and
R&B so I don't nothing
so I mean you guys did have a pretty
like fast trajectory I think do you kind
of like Iowa's one because I've never
been on that fast track yet so it's like
do you feel do you feel like in that
moment you kind of like take things for
granted a lot because I see a lot of
like even youtubers right
I think they a lot of youtubers forget
where they were before they had
something great happen right and so I
see them complain about a lot of these
small things and I'm like bro what would
you be doing without this [ __ ] you know
what I mean so that that that thing you
kind of get your perspective gets a
little [ __ ] a little bit right that
ever happened for you guys a lot yeah
well there were like I said in the
beginning there were years where I think
that appreciation was there where we
don't stop and say this is crazy how are
we playing Warped Tour right now we're
on the main stage today how did we get
this tour opening up for Angels and
Airwaves and save the day like this is
what is happening but I think after
years of gone by you know six or seven
years in and then we were on the major
label and we had some money backing us
and we were in a bus at that point
and then I think after that after that
much time then you start to forget about
where you started and why you're doing
it it just becomes normal at that point
it's just yeah you just lose track of
your your humble beginnings not lately
no lately we are very much reminded of
how it started
we're starting all over again yeah I
mean this tour were in a van meg and I
are driving we don't even have money for
a trailer so all of our merch is gonna
be all over we don't have money to hire
a light got a lighting guys sound guy
mega night or managing we're booking all
the hotels kind of like how many people
can we squeeze in one hotel room for
this so it's definitely back to doing
everything on our own you know what's
weird about me though like I had this
I'm you know my friends say this is very
odd about me too
I [ __ ] like that I like struggling it
makes me want to work harder so yeah so
like when I don't like struggling so
like it's weird because I stopped doing
YouTube for the longest [ __ ] time and
when you do that like this algorithm
happens whether you get to get forgotten
so you'll have one point four million
followers but only about like twenty
thousand will see your [ __ ] yeah so it's
weird and I'm more excited to do work
and now than I was then when every video
I had had a quarter mil half a mil half
a mil half a mil and you know money was
great somebody's okay now but it's just
like then you like that's why I was
mentioned you kind of take things for
granted but now that things are slowed
down and I get like 10% of those views I
have to work for it again I'm Way more
motivated and I'm a lot happier which is
so [ __ ] odd well why you gotta
explain that part of it but why are you
a lot happier now you know I was
thinking about it the other day and I
don't know if it's because I enjoy being
the underdog you know and it's it's
almost like when you do stand-up right
and so when I when I do stand-up
sometimes at these college shows it's
great because I it's more of a
fanservice thing right they want to see
me make these jokes they want to laugh
but when I go to a comedy club and I
have to make these people who don't know
me laugh it makes me feel better because
you'll see a lot of stand-up shows on on
whatever Netflix and whatever whatnot
right you say and arguably from any kind
of standpoint their standup is [ __ ]
hot trash but people will laugh because
they
have a fanbase so if they perform that
at a random Club would they get laughs
I'm not [ __ ] sure so that is the part
that keeps me really excited where I I
have to figure out a way to be
entertaining without the fact that
people just expect to laugh anyways
right so it's that it's that weird type
of motivation it's terrible business
model by the way it's a terrible
terrible business model like when people
see you have a certain amount of success
and you just throw it away just to just
because you feel like things were just
given to you it's kind of dumb when you
really think about it like that but this
is that that same type of excitement
that I had when I first started doing
stand-up so did you do that on purpose I
didn't do it on purpose I just kind of
got over it like I got over doing these
videos like like I used to do this thing
called carpool confessions on my channel
and that [ __ ] did so [ __ ] well it was
very easy content it hit like half a mil
every [ __ ] time yeah so money was
coming in like nothing yeah and then I
did it for about two months I think and
I was like this is too easy so I shut it
down and I did something else like what
the [ __ ] are you doing I was like I
don't know it's just too easy like I
don't I don't want this like I like I I
tried it I'm done
even like when I did if I did a film I
did it once and now it's hard for me to
do another one really yeah because I I
kind of checked it off the list so it's
like oh good I'll move on and I'll try
something else now like it's hard for me
too I like I don't need to continue to
do something if I know I can do it once
then I kind of start to fall off a
little bit because I don't care about it
as much anymore do you feel like it
would be different with different kinds
of films I remember because I was
talking to Khalif about guk when I first
watched that movie and I did it it's
it's your very broad human hmm because I
think somebody can be introduced to you
by one thing like I knew you for comedy
in stand-up comedy and your videos and
then all of a sudden I watched [ __ ] and
you know I've been in acting class for
years and years and years and I watch
your performance and I'm not just trying
to blow smoke up your ass it was amazing
I don't think the movie was great and
then also I would I was like he sings
and you sing really well so then you're
a singer and then I was telling Meg on
the way here I was like David's kind of
like who I would be in another life
because I love matcha
I would own sip I would own my own ice
cream shop and then I would be in this
amazing indie movie and a singer I'm
like we are the same person but you do
all these different things I mean how do
you balance that and even with guk like
that was such a specific movie what if
you got something that required such a
different skill set of you I mean I just
don't think I care about failing that's
why like I just don't give a [ __ ] this
is one of those relevant filming about
anything if I [ __ ] fail I fail Oh
cares right cuz that's that's just
something I had to learn and I talked
about this on the last podcast and it
started when I was really young I used
to be very scared of everything my dad
hated that about me he [ __ ] hated
that about me he hated the fact that I
couldn't go up and order my own food at
a [ __ ] McDonald's because I was so
scared of interacting with people and my
dad hated that he used to [ __ ] beat
my ass because I just was such a timid
little kid I just would not interact
with human beings like I liked talking I
was a class clown but that was just a
way for me to try to divert my
nervousness right and after a while I
think I honestly say it has to start
it's probably started really around like
my junior of high school and then from
then on it just got better and better
and better and then so my junior year of
high school when I was younger I was so
scared of like people's perception of me
right I didn't I didn't join quiet till
I was a senior and I wanted to join
choir when I was a freshman that is so
surprising to hear yeah so I just didn't
want to do it because I was scared of
what people thought about me I don't
want my friends to call me a [ __ ] they
did singing you're who the [ __ ] cares
I'm leaving anyways right I'm gonna
leave I'm gonna go to college [ __ ] all
you guys and in that moment my senior
year of high school was the happiest
that I ever was in my four years of high
school because I didn't care I just
didn't care anymore I figured out how to
study I figured out how to read a
[ __ ] book you know what I mean and
when when when I started clicking these
things together I just started trying to
implement that every [ __ ] day and so
now it's just evolved into something
where I try it out and if it doesn't
work it doesn't [ __ ] work this
podcast everybody told me not to do it
they were like don't do a podcast you're
gonna kill your channel I killed my
channel but this podcast does better
than
channel now it was a big [ __ ] risk the
first few months there wasn't a single
cent coming to this channel and I had to
go without like three or four months
with with no income you know but I
rather figure out what happens if I fail
than if I don't do it and if it fails
then I'll pick up my pieces and I'll
figure something else out because in my
mind
nothing's gonna [ __ ] stop me I'll
figure something else out I don't have
this thing of I'm scared to do something
because of what other people think or
what I feel about it so I like for
example um I had a relative that
graduated college he graduated and he
didn't this is something that I hate he
didn't want to take a part-time job
because he thought he was above it that
mentality pisses me off a lot because
for me I'll take anything if I don't
have something I will do whatever I can
to have that so if there's like a
certain level of life that I wanted to
achieve right let's say I needed to make
like seven or eight grand to live a
certain life right
I would work seven jobs just to get that
because that's what that situation I put
myself in like for somebody like that he
says I'm above driving for uber I'm
above doing this stuff because I am this
type of human being you don't really get
anywhere so for me I just don't care
about family I'll do anything I can to
get to what I want but once I get it I
shift a lot so that's that's a it's not
something I suggest people do but it's
just what makes me happy right so once I
did goob it's very hard for me to try to
work on another film now like I'm trying
my best but I'm not inspired to it's
it's I start writing and then I stop I
start writing in that I stop yeah when
it wasn't like that for that film but I
feel like for you you're such a
entrepreneur and your own person that I
feel like sometimes when you you are the
type of person that I would imagine
would be in a movie that you were a
large part of the creative process oh
for sure because I was talking to Khalif
about auditioning and he was telling me
about when you were going in for
auditions and stuff and thinking about
you going into an audition room just I
don't know you very well to be honest
personally yeah even though I hear about
you a lot but and I see your videos and
stuff but just thinking about you going
into an audition process because I I'm
the opposite of you in that sense and I
I mean I actually want to talk to you
more about how you can overcome that
fear because I care so much what people
think
about me and I get so nervous of
performing even my singing teacher the
other day was telling me about this beta
blocker that some of her students are on
that kind of helped calm your nerves
and I when talk to my doctor about this
because I get so much anxiety and she
said just because my body and different
things I can't take it but that's to the
point but when I go in and into an
audition I'm like oh my god please like
me and then I sit in the waiting room
and I see somebody that is like way
better than me in all these different
ways in my brain I'm like this person's
prettier they're skinnier they're taller
they're they're more Korean looking
they're less Korean looking they're
whatever and I just go crazy in my head
but I was like thinking about you in an
audition room and I'm like David
wouldn't care and he wouldn't oh I
absolutely do not care I do it this way
and you didn't like that you know if the
casting director says do it a little bit
like this and I I don't really feel like
it fits the character the story I'll
just say okay well I want to make sure
she like okay let's do it but I could
just see you being like um no this is
the way I see this person and I want to
be more like like how if you said that
swish and senior-year like what was it a
moment
was it an event that happened or was it
kind of the span of you always kind of
just I'm gonna take another risk and I'm
gonna you just I think it's this point
where you kind of look at yourself and
you start hating yourself a little bit
like I I'm there it's uh I just you know
life is very short you know and you know
where I grew up to had a bunch of losers
you know and I I'm already past what I
think that I was already capable when I
was younger which is crazy right so I
had a conversation with my fiancee she
goes so what are your goals I was like
personal goals I was like to be honest
with you I don't know like my I guess I
have an overarching goal which is just
to be happy and I do whatever I can to
fill that so I don't have this thing
where I can't it's hard for me to stop
myself from doing something because of
something that I lack which is
completely within my control to not care
it's completely within your control
right so I get nervous in auditions
right I go in there but once it's done
it's out of my control
it's a problem for me when I see when
people try to control things that you
cannot control no matter what you
[ __ ] do you cannot control it so
what's the whole point in wasting your
time thinking about it nothing is gonna
happen it's the same advice that I give
to these guys who are afraid to approach
women they go well what happens
nothing's gonna happen you're not gonna
[ __ ] die dude she's gonna say no you
might cry a little bit but you'll
[ __ ] live go for another one and
that's just how I approach things now -
even with these [ __ ] auditions like I
go in I try it out if I get a callback
I do if I don't [ __ ] it who cares I can
only do the best that I can do at the
end of the day even on the other side of
like casting they're just looking for
the best person that fits this role
right or sometimes people just suck a
lot of dick and something happens right
and you know even with acting - like I
always say this it's really something
that's completely out of your control is
something that's out of the casting
directors control it's really about who
has the [ __ ] money right so even even
this when I was when I started after I
did Google I got to in I got to speak to
a lot of execs and what I really found
out just from talking to people
constantly and getting drinks with them
is that casting directors just opened
the door like this and that's as far as
they can get it other than that it's in
everybody else's hands the director
depends on how much power the director
has who the director is if it's not them
then it'll be up to the network there's
a network like you enough right do they
want to put their money behind you
sometimes and I say about in my personal
opinion from what I've seen and what
I've heard 70% of the time they've
already casted who they want you are the
backup to the backup mm-hmm so you you
already had the chip stacked against you
and in your cases specifically because
you're an actor that's also the life
that you chose so if you're choosing
this [ __ ] life you have to expect
that out of everything that's gonna
happen I always tell people with acting
it's like going into a [ __ ] job
interview [ __ ] 12 times a week for
the rest of your [ __ ] life and having
every person tell you that you're not
good enough yeah you know that sounds
pretty accurate you know what I mean and
sometimes these casting directors don't
even tell you what you did wrong and you
just have to mull over it at home just
God what did I do wrong you don't
[ __ ] know some of these catches well
they don't even [ __ ] tell you that's
how I feel when I get
ejected from clubs No okay go megwin hey
Meg went to girl and dress right do I
need to wear more pink what did I do
yeah I couldn't get into any clubs in
Berlin when she went she was a solo into
one club
it's called berghain it was notoriously
famous for not getting in mm-hmm
but yeah that's how my my experience
just had to wear like saran wrap as a
dressing I literally saw so many nipples
in that line like male and female
nipples with clothes like around them
but the nipples were just completely
exposed yes they're dressing Raptors oh
you had plenty of time while waiting in
line to fix your shirt I was like wait
anybody have some scissors Larry off
real quick and they just hang in the
clubs that girls like it's pretty easy
for a girl though that's what I thought
I'm a female done ya know so just like
casting Mike was walking away from the
club just wondering what was I too tall
was I what was it
I wonder if you just slowly started
bringing your dress down that rope would
have just opened up slowly
the amount of nipple you show it just
gives me opens my skirt was like going
higher and then I was like this is
ridiculous like I'm just gonna go get a
kebab leave I haven't been to a [ __ ]
club in like three or four years I been
to maybe three clubs in my entire holy
really but I was in Berlin yeah and
Berlin is the place where the club
starts at Friday morning and goes till
Sunday after Sunday night mmm so I went
it's Sunday at 11:00 a.m. end of the
club like the party there's no what you
in still want to let me in that's a self
esteem destroyer right there oh man I
left nothing I feel sorry checked my
self-worth just with that bouncer that's
so [ __ ] funny like I I remember Vegas
too if I just wanted to get into club I
just had to bring a couple of
girlfriends like hey can y'all just get
me in like here y'all y'all [ __ ] show
some tits and not just trail right
behind
I just hold the back of their hair like
this look I'm with them I'm with them
please like that in Berlin yeah one time
I got into this club in Vegas and it was
packing they weren't letting anybody in
and then literally a my managers walks
in he goes yo man we gotta get inside
we're talking to somebody real quick and
you're stopping me from this meeting
goes I'm sorry bro we just walk right in
he [ __ ] did it I was like that's a
[ __ ] amazing Wow how did you do that
he just made it seem like it was [ __ ]
important and he was an important person
and it was great Wow I guess you just
have to make them feel like they're
making a huge mistake to not let you in
yeah exactly
or just start coughing in their face and
say you have some kind of crazy venereal
disease that's what I got [ __ ] insane
AIDS dunno just scoff in their face and
walk in but you guys are going on tour
soon this yeah we leave in two days for
our first shows in Salt Lake City where
we're from were from Utah and then LA we
play New York Boston and it's our first
tour in a while and our first practice
[Laughter]
we need to play the biggest thing was
playing together as it as a team like we
we just practiced alone in our room all
the time and Meg's living in Utah and
I'm here and we weren't really listening
to each other or paying attention to
each other so it was I don't know and
and playing live is such a different Oh
animal are you gonna play live more I
haven't done anything live in like five
or six years it's been a long time but
cuz you're starting up music again yeah
that's just for fun though like it's fun
but like I don't know if I the whole
live aspect is the most difficult thing
[ __ ] ever
because I mean first of all just I don't
people if you guys don't do music out
there singing live singing in your room
and singing on a [ __ ] mic or three
different [ __ ] oh my gosh yes
recording is the most annoying thing
I've ever done in my life I get pissed
like my buddy Ozzy we do music together
he just sees me got Michael [ __ ]
[ __ ]
right cuz I could hear every [ __ ]
note that's flat or sharp and it bothers
me and your timing my timing is always
off because I haven't recorded on a mic
in ages and I can't
get the [ __ ] timing down and I get
frustrated and I get mad then he gets
worse and worse and worse
so live performances are even way worse
because you just have so much [ __ ] to
think about dude I don't know how you
guys do that it it's it's a lot and
there's so many things outside of your
control like the sound the sound is a
major thing or something goes wrong with
the tracks or the instruments or you
drink too much the day before whatever
it is you really just have to be careful
and it really depends on who you hire as
your bandmates - how good are they like
if they [ __ ] suck ass your [ __ ]
specifically if your drummer [ __ ]
sucks like my god dude yeah it's we're
actually pretty lucky we've been playing
with the same guitar player for like 10
years now awesome so it's kind of like
family I think that's why people like
performing in small cafes you have your
guitar and you [ __ ] up it's true and you
can hear everything that way so it's
really nice yeah I feel like it's a lot
like working out like when you first get
into working out the first times really
hard and you just don't want to go and
it's just you're getting your muscle
memory back you know but if you go
consistently you know how you get into
that space it just feels good you go you
know what you're doing I think that our
first practice was definitely like that
first day back at the gym but then the
second one is a little better and the
third one's a little better and like
pretty soon eventually you hit the
groove and then you're finally where you
want to be on the last day of tour
record that one please and then tours
over and then you're like finally it's
kind of cool though like I think hello
everyone this podcast is brought to you
by keeps my friends out there my male
friends out there are you worried about
male pattern baldness are you worried
about balding too fast too soon or maybe
it's already struck you a little bit
well guess what I got the solution for
your life we're talking about keeps baby
well let me give you some fact eyes real
quick about keeps and male pattern
baldness just to put this in perspective
two out of three guys will experience
some form of male pattern baldness by
the time they are 35 the good news
with today's advancements in science
keeps offers proven treatments that can
combat the symptoms of hair loss keeps
has revolutionized the way men are
treated for hair loss you used to have
to go to the doctor's office for your
hair loss prescription now things to
keeps you can visit a doctor online and
get medication deliver to your home no
more waiting rooms no more pharmacy
checkout lines get doctors attentions
and discreet drug delivery all from the
comfort and privacy of your own home
remember prevention is key keeps
treatments really work they are up to 90
percent effective at reducing and
stopping further hair loss the sooner
you start using keeps the more hair
you'll grow or maybe even save so act
fast and I say grow because many men
even experience hair regrowth with keeps
treatments mmm it's a possibility my
friends so listen if you're ready to
take action and prevent hair loss go to
keeps calm slash brain to receive your
first month of treatment for free that's
K EEP s.com slash brain once again keeps
calm slash brain to receive your first
month of treatment for free that's K EEP
s calm slash brain I think maybe for me
the hard part is just once you do
something for so long like how would you
guys keep still keep it fun right that's
the hard part I think it's how do you do
something that you've done so
repetitiously over and over and keep it
fun that you want to do it again over
and over again you find different
aspects to be curious about
so before I don't maybe it was um the
love it was the love of music generally
and just being excited for to perform on
stage and probably a little bit of boy
chasing like a lot of boy chasing you
know early 20s yes now my perspectives
changed because I I've had a lot of time
to think about how much I miss playing
music when we weren't playing music
mm-hmm and now I really love connecting
with people okay so meeting you in this
podcast about that yeah yeah we're
talking about music but I get to hear
about you know how you conquered your
fears and how you're not afraid to do
anything and fill your energy
and you know so connecting with people
it's within music but it's it keeps it
fresh because you can look at it from
this different thing like what you're
getting out of it and like my love of
travel and exploring new places has
really blossomed since I've in my 30s
you know music is such a powerful thing
that do you guys ever get surprised
about let's say a fan comes up and they
just talk about some of your old music
and what listening to those songs help
them through something that's like music
is so [ __ ] powerful like you never
think that right you would think it's
like motivational speaking or something
else but something music does something
to people it people rip like for example
I remember this one time so I got dumped
during I was listening to funny enough
what album was it it was listened to
Kanye West it was it was graduation and
I was listening to the jay-z black album
and then I was also listening
surprisingly to this Corinne Bailey Rae
elebrate already got one weird one that
weird one man was ariana grande that was
like that was my weird breakup album
forcep and when I think about that those
albums come to play every time anything
from that from those albums plays it
reminds me of her which is so [ __ ]
odd right like if I listen to a Corinne
Bailey Rae song I'm reminded when I was
when I was 19 years old and I got
[ __ ] dumped and I think about that
[ __ ] and I'm like dude that's [ __ ]
crazy
and those were they weren't really
connected you know but if I listen to
that song it affects me emotionally
almost so if I listen to anything creme
de leur it reminds me of my girlfriend
when I was 18 to 19 years old yeah
that's so [ __ ] weird dude yeah it's
like it musics very nostalgic and
there's a lot of memories that kind of
be kept in songs which is weird oh yeah
so I love Brian McKnight dude I got
dumped oh I got dumped you have no idea
when I got dug this [ __ ] was so [ __ ]
funny my best friend reminds me of this
[ __ ] but I remember I call the mum was
like yo bro I'm [ __ ] sad let's just
go get something to eat this month I
could dude he saw me cry as I ate into a
Wendy's double cheeseburger just [ __ ]
buying that [ __ ] that should taste like
nothing I remember eyes
Oh tears we're coming down he goes dog
you're crying eating Burgers and Fries
brothers looks [ __ ] pathetic really
but then I went home I [ __ ] put that
Brian nice CD and I was like oh god my
pain did so I've been to like for Brian
midnight concerts because the time I was
so [ __ ] heartbroken I knew every
lyric to every song from like three or
four albums of his that's kind of
amazing I also think it's kind of
amazing that you were crying not that
you're crying but I was crying a lot
well Megan I talk about that a lot we
have a song called boys can cry but it
really is about the kind of masculinity
of mecca's our dad is totally like I've
seen him cry once in my life you know
he's that guy and he's also like
therapies for for dumb people like
therapies for crazy people when I'm like
therapy is for everybody everybody needs
a therapist and it's kind of that thing
of can men open up to their I mean do
you feel I mean I'm from a very
emotional family so like therapy
I mean therapy has this weird stigma
towards it right and people don't
realize the funny thing is every time I
hear somebody say that type of [ __ ]
mego therapies were [ __ ] act like
that's funny because you sound like you
need therapy be most how do all of us
it's true you know they have all this
like repressed [ __ ] and and everybody
gets therapy in one way or another
whether it's from a professional or not
we usually get it from our friends and
family when we talk at our problems so
one of the one of the biggest advice
that I gave to actually my fiance when
her friends talk to her about problems I
say you know what don't even give them
advice I think people are smart enough
to figure out their own problems they
just need somebody to bounce their ideas
off of so for example her friend went
through this whole thing with her
boyfriend and their breakup and you know
when she was first talking to her on the
phone she goes oh yeah he's such an
[ __ ] blah blahs like stop don't say
that you don't need to say that what you
need to do is just listen to her and ask
her questions and she can figure it out
herself cuz I met her friend she's very
intelligent and as she started asking
her questions and having her speak she
figured it out she understood as she
felt a lot better and that's that's
everybody's normal form of therapy they
just don't call it therapy right so
therapies is for everybody everybody
gets us one way
I get from my mom I call my mom almost
every day so we talked on the phone we
talked about problems usually I find out
that I'm wrong but then so like whatever
Muriel will piss me off I call my mama
you know what she did she did this she
goes mmm now you maybe you could have
done it this way I'm like a [ __ ]
should have called you god damn it I'm
wrong and I just hang up the phone what
yeah I mean I came from a very emotional
family like I said I call my mom every
day you know we talked on the phone if
I'm in the car she's the first person
that I call oh that's so nice yeah so we
have I I call her because she's really
fun to talk to she's really really fun
and um it's it's like my therapy almost
I guess like yeah let me ask you if
you're working something out mm-hmm do
you think that there's a point where you
should not call your mom or talk to a
friend and try to like work it through
yourself like when is the time to ask
for support and when is the time to be
like I got this I don't know I don't
even think about that yeah I feel like I
should talk to somebody I just talked to
them mm-hmm I know I'm I I don't have
that thing in between it gets me in
trouble a lot you know I'm learning to
like maybe hold back some of my thoughts
but I just feel like if I if I add
something else that think about it
stresses me out that's why something a
majority of the time I don't give a [ __ ]
about what I wear because that's another
thing for me to think about it's another
[ __ ] thing I got a wake-up see if I
gotta boogers in my eyes and [ __ ] and do
all the sort of stuff so Marielle too
she goes one time you just came out of
no she goes you never look into a mirror
I'm like what do you mean she goes
whenever we leave you don't check to see
if your hair is nice you don't check to
see your clothes she goes you just get
up and you walk out and because I just I
stopped caring asthma cific aliy as a
comic - who the [ __ ] cares what I look
like I'm just supposed to be funny I'm
just supposed to have something to say
so if I do something I just try not to
think too much into it because why yeah
why that is really smart I'm learning a
lot from this conversation I hope I can
go away from this podcast carrying a
little bit less about you will find out
everything you'll find out how much
happier you are like how much happy
you are and you'll find out a lot of the
positive things about yourself that
become highlighted right because you're
not focused on all this [ __ ] right
so for me to like that's why I didn't
know I was [ __ ] fat for like 30 years
no nobody [ __ ] told me you know I was
walking around like I was this [ __ ] you
know and then you know the doctor comes
up like a bro kind of obese so I'm like
hey you're a hater did you know and I
had and I found out just through health
problems and you know Muriel she told me
I was fat and I was like she might have
something to this you know you look
awesome thank you you know I don't you
have it you have an ouchie
I know forgive me from I can't even I
can't look at blood meg can't look at
blood either she sees it she'll straight
up pass out that's okay it's not it's
not bleeding anymore
but it is a badass cut it's like from
fighting yeah but this is okay - I'm
okay with this this makes me feel like I
did something today yeah yeah this is
awesome but yeah it's just I think
that's like the general thing is just
stop caring so much about stuff that
doesn't really matter who cares like
even when you guys perform to have
[ __ ] fun at the end of the day and
I'll tell you this here's some other
perspective I go to these shows
sometimes and I'm sent to judge talent
contest mm-hmm some of the most terrible
musicians I've ever heard in my life but
they play like they're the best [ __ ] on
earth yeah let me tell you this [ __ ]
story okay I was out in Buffalo New York
right shout-out to Buffalo New York you
guys have some of the most untalented
people on earth I show ya great wings by
the way they [ __ ] it this kid comes up
this he's like a Chinese international
student and I [ __ ] love this kid I
told the story in this podcast before
but I love this kid so much that he cuz
he made me laugh his performance was so
[ __ ] funny so he had this guitar he
goes up and he sings his lady gaga song
in a thick Chinese accent I was cracking
up I was literally dying so hard in the
front I was grabbing everybody like yeah
this guy's [ __ ] funny
talent show is done I'm supposed to give
everybody a score from 1 to 10 I give
this [ __ ] at 10 everybody looks
at me and they go are you serious I'm
like what do you mean he was [ __ ]
killing it he had me die he goes dude he
was serious and you laugh
than his face through his whole set I
was mortified I was in I thought it was
a comedy set he was serious and the
point of that story is yes it was
confident as [ __ ] and he was enjoying
afterwards he comes out to me he goes
hey David maybe we should do music
together because we could combine our
powers unleash utt the [ __ ] up dude how
[ __ ] dare you but that's how
confident he is and he's so happy doing
what he's doing he was going to drop out
of college to pursue music and I told
him no was I you wait fun with the music
and see what happens because he was
gonna throw his [ __ ] life away but if
somebody like that can enjoy what he's
doing and pursue it that type of passion
that you guys already had the skills
talent and the [ __ ] the experience
then you know what's there really to
worry about at that point I mean there
is something pretty amazing about
watching somebody go up and just not
give a [ __ ] oh yeah
like that has never been but I mean for
you okay
music if you have a bad song generally I
mean I have had some things thrown at me
on stage not gonna lie but generally
people kind of will just look at their
phone and get over you but with stand-up
it's an immediate reaction I mean how oh
I've done sets where people were dead
silent so what do you do you kind of
shut down in your brain no the bad I
called him the bad voices like come in
like you suck you're a loser like jump
off a cliff oh I'm a sick [ __ ] I golf
man these people have no sense of humor
yeah but that's what you do a stand-up
comic says you'll do these jokes
some of them we'll hit some of them
won't then you have to go back and work
your set they're all testers so you go
that's still a funny joke they didn't
laugh it's probably because of the way
that I said it or the way I did
something the same thing with music it's
like there was something off about this
set this is how the song is and I don't
think you know there's something wrong
with this and you have to rework it
again we work it and that's the same
mentality to have a stand-up I do a joke
people sometimes people boo sometimes
people they're not feeling it but I'm
like no this joke is [ __ ] funny I
know it is but what am I doing wrong and
I find out the timing was off where I
placed it was off the setup was off and
I work it again and it kills a [ __ ]
room you can't really control what other
people other people feel about your [ __ ]
I'm just trying to control what I can
and if you go up and it bombs again then
maybe you're wrong maybe it wasn't that
funny then you go ask other and then I
go ask my comic friends I'm like hey
what do you think about this show can
they go yeah they do have a good sense
of humor I [ __ ] suck and I just cross
it out and they move on yeah you know
it's all mentality a certain point and
I'm not saying that I don't [ __ ] have
doubts as [ __ ] and I don't have like the
bad boys in my head I just had to tell
that guy to shut the [ __ ] up constantly
all the time yeah even with putting up
content on my YouTube I stopped doing
content because I got it in my head that
this was too easy for me and I deserve
to do things that are better and bigger
right
so I stopped doing this whole YouTube
thing and I was like no I could take
this and make something else I wish I
did I did [ __ ] you know I did it but I
kind of neglected something that I
enjoyed because I thought that I could
do something bigger and better than that
but I did enjoy it mmm I really did and
I kind of forgot the reason why I
started doing comedy in the first place
I stopped I started doing comedy and not
music because I like the way that comedy
connected with people versus the way my
music did because with comedy like
sometimes people would say I was having
the worst [ __ ] day and you made me
laugh and it changed my life around it
was like cool I'm gonna do comedy for
that reason I get that and I forgot you
know we were I was rooting to use some
of our Instagram messages yesterday and
it was just really it just makes you
feel good it makes me remember why
you're doing it in the first place so
for sure I mean it's amazing man when
somebody comes up like for example I
remember I had to show out in Denver and
this is during the time I was trying to
lose weight before and the reason why I
did this whole it was called funny fat
fit it was because a lot of kids were
connecting me to their Oh being
overweight and they were okay with it I
wasn't okay with being overweight it was
just what I was I was just like I'm just
a fat guy whatever [ __ ] it like I didn't
care so much so okay well let me just
try to change people's perspective
around and I started doing this funny
fat fit thing and when I was in Denver
there was just kid that came up and he
was super nervous couldn't really look
me in the eye very very overweight and
he was like looking down at the floor I
voice was shaking and stuff
and he was like yo I'm gonna try to lose
weight because she did this whole funny
fat fit thing or whatever and I was like
oh cool and then he told me he goes this
is the first time I
actually left my room in a few months
and the reason why is because he was in
that theater when Batman was playing in
the shooter came in and then just
started spraying on people he was in
there and he survived and that was the
first time he left his room since that
happened just to come to the show to see
me
so plug embraced him whatever so I did a
show in Denver again the next year
because how the kid comes up to me just
happy as [ __ ] super forward just fit as
[ __ ] right kick comes up you go do you
remember me and I'm like no you are he
goes I was that kid that came up to you
last time and watching funny if that fit
I lost all this weight and I gained my
confidence back [ __ ] blew my mind I
didn't know and I got a little pissed
cuz like how did you lose more weight to
be broke like you stupid son of a [ __ ]
you know but those are the reasons why I
forget this is why I did this was
because even if I can't affect everybody
there are individuals that I can affect
in a positive way and so that's that's
like the other Drive that I started you
know creating more content I started I
opened up a patreon again because well
the channel stopped making money as much
as as much money as before and I want
expand his podcast out but the great
thing about the patreon was that it
gives me that connection with people now
I can create content specifically for
them and it motivates me again because
now I have that connection it's that
same type of connection I have with that
kid in Denver you know yeah and you guys
have that with your music as well so my
thing is you guys should just go out
there and have fun because how long are
you guys gonna do this for are you gonna
do with your 80 years old probably not
so while you guys can and you enjoy it
just [ __ ] have fun life is short I
don't think people really realize that
it doesn't really click in anybody's
[ __ ] head life is so [ __ ] short
and it's finite as [ __ ] you know yeah
every day we don't enjoy ourselves as a
day that we lose that we just hate our
lives I think I can't do that I just
can't do it it just it's a waste for me
like why I mean I I think when we when
we say these things people don't realize
it you have food in your stomach you
have a roof over your head but on top of
that you guys have a fanbase you have
people you've actually done stuff in in
this lifetime already in your guys's age
that most people will never get to and
they wanted to do that their whole lives
and that's fun that's something to be
said it's huge right so that's why I
said with like [ __ ] I'm okay if I die
tomorrow I'm fine because I got to do
something that I really wanted
you guys have achieved something that
nobody I know people back at home they
wanted to do music like you guys and
they couldn't do it they couldn't me
well whether it was a talent thing
whether they didn't have the dedication
or the cars just weren't stacked the
right way they just never got there but
you guys had that had it and still have
it so at this point for me how I see it
for you guys everything's a bonus
everything's a [ __ ] bonus now you've
achieved this much now everything else
that you get to have it's just the icing
on the cake it's a blessing to get to do
what you do I am blessed I'm blessed
that I get to have this podcast like you
me I'll get it Terry right because like
so it's like you know I always talk
about this with my mom because we grew
up like so [ __ ] poor you know and uh
oh [ __ ] okay it's like it's crazy cuz I
remember like my parents opening this
door
they had like a shelf and people don't
realize how hard it was for us because
we came to this country with nothing and
so I remember as a kid we couldn't
afford shelves to put like our products
on it was just like cardboard boxes you
know and I look at it now and like I
have it a [ __ ] apartment like I have
all this [ __ ] people take that [ __ ] for
granted so much and it pisses me off
because I'm like dude you don't you
don't realize how fortunate you are
because there are people that would kill
to be in your person that's why I love
doing mission trips mission trips helped
me out a lot because when I when I went
to on these mission trips I really got
to see how other people lived that's why
I love traveling yeah traveling puts
things in such a great perspective
because you never you you always take
these small things for granted right and
you know I had a friend named Amanda
suit yeah yeah I know man right Amanda
asked me one time soon when we went to
go out to eat she goes she goes honey
why are you so happy on therm I'm happy
all the time I'm just grateful I'm
grateful
like I'm just grateful that I have these
[ __ ] things I'm grateful that I get
to meet people like you I'm grateful
that I have friends I grew up as a kid
the hardest time making friends because
I was so unapologetic for who I was like
I just couldn't change but that's why I
always tell some of these kids online is
so
I tell him just be yourself and you'll
find the right group you you will
eventually you will you just have to be
willing to put yourself out there and so
I just I just try to be grateful for the
things that I have all the hood and tell
me I'm grateful that I'm a fiancee which
I blows my [ __ ] mind till this day
I'm grateful that I have just anything
like it's crazy just it just to be an
immigrant to come to this country with
parents who couldn't speak the [ __ ]
language they have a business that's
still going on right now they raise two
kids that aren't a bunch of thugs they
grew up in a [ __ ] bad neighborhood my
best friend's a [ __ ] doctor like that
blows my [ __ ] mind I looked at him
the other day when I went to Sacramento
say do you realize your [ __ ] doctor
bro from Sacramento California from
South Sacramento with [ __ ] hooded ass
area you're a [ __ ] doctor dude
amazing and it's and I told we're
breaking stereotypes you're a black dude
that's a doctor trouble he's a comedian
know it all [ __ ] up so I think that
always just helps me enjoy what I'm
doing and it kind of gets rid of this
whole thing of like you know why do i
why do I suck like why do I feel this
way like [ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] that
[ __ ] boys man you're gonna go through
that every day for the rest of your life
but it's your job to make sure that you
silence that voice and just have great
people around you that will lift you up
like it all doesn't [ __ ] matter like
it's if you're waking up every day and
the first person that beats you up is
yourself you're already [ __ ] up like
let the world do that to you let
everybody else try to bring you down but
you shouldn't do that to yourself you
should you should be the one to tell
yourself you're the [ __ ] right cuz I
can't do that as I said I walked around
fat for my whole life cuz I thought I
had a six-pack nobody told me I thought
was you don't mean like I I literally
walked into other places looking at
other fat people even though I was
arguably fatter than them and I was like
they need to get their life together
that's how [ __ ] I am you know so I
think like you guys have something great
going on and I'm you know I'm kind of
glad that you going back into music
because I'm doing music right now for
fun because I lost that magic because I
kept on trying to turn it into a [ __ ]
business you know so yeah I kind of I
gotta do coverage that everybody knows
and then I gotta make music that
everybody likes but what about me why
can't I just do [ __ ] that I like right
so I like I did like a [ __ ] like a
Kyle Dion cover and people know [ __ ]
Kyle be on it's not a lot a lot you know
but I did it because I enjoyed it and
people like to me
so that's that's the satisfaction that I
get you can hear that and music though
when you can just tell somebody is
enjoying it yeah and I don't know I like
listening listening to that and you
could also see different like your music
is very intimate okay and so oh man my
favorites um all I need I just really
love acoustic oh yeah really chill
acoustic stuff but it's fun because you
can almost show different sides of your
personality that people really can't see
but um I wrote that song when I was
[ __ ] 19 what yeah I wrote that when I
was 19 and then my uh my buddies
finished up they wrote the bridge for me
and that's it everything was nineteen
years old when I got dumped Seema isn't
that kind of it's almost like a journal
entry that's out there in the world
yeah and it's still affecting people meg
wrote one of my favorite songs she's
ever written when she was fifteen called
masterpiece and it's just it's all these
kind of little yeah things that remind
you and not only his masterpiece I mean
masterpiece is special to me because the
time it was written and that was when we
really didn't care cuz nobody knew
anything about us we weren't doing
anything in music and that was such a
good talk for me to listen to because
I'm constantly judging myself and like
oh my gosh we're getting older like
we're like how much longer we gonna do
this and it's kind of that thing of I
was thinking about aging and like when
you're 10 years old and you're singing
it's oh this is so cute you're singing
when you're 15 it's like maybe you
should get into lessons and make this a
thing and then when you're 20 it's like
this is fun and romantic and and then
when you're 30 it's kind of like oh are
you still you're still going and then 35
40 it's like it gets almost sad to
people and and I'm kind of wondering
does it have to be that way um I don't
think it does I think um the the
foundation has to be right why why do
you do it yeah why like acting to
specifically acting why do you do it
a majority of actors don't make it you
have to love doing this yeah you have to
love getting emotionally battered all
the [ __ ] time so if you can do this
[ __ ] every day for the rest of your life
whether you make it or not isn't even in
your in your mind then that you're
probably on the right track because it
makes you happy like it's any type of
art form it's hard to make cuz it's not
it wasn't originally started as a
business that's something that came
after it was people just wanted to
express themselves in the right way how
they wanted to do it and if you can do
it just for the joy of it obviously
there's a business aspect that you want
to think about as well but you I don't
think that people should think about if
I don't make it because if you think if
I don't make it you're kind of already
not in the right business that's so true
right because there's people who are
great actors now they all started
somewhere people pop off really late
[ __ ] Idris Elba popped off super
[ __ ] late in his life but he's like
the biggest thing out there and they're
there and that's why I love about acting
and comedy it's timeless it doesn't
matter you may not become the the best
actress right now during the time you
want it to be but if you love the
[ __ ] art what does it matter
but what does it really matter dude like
even stand up
like I I do stand I haven't done
stand-up in a while and consistently
because it's not something that I'm
interested in but I'll only get better
with stand-up with time so if I tackle
this ten years from now in my 40s it'll
probably better stand than I was when
I'm thirty right now and that's the same
thing with acting you're just stacking
your chips right now life experiences
all these conversations that you're
having it affects your acting and
especially even especially with music
especially when you write when you go
through these things your music gets
better you write better things because
you had these conversations with people
and you just kind of collect we're all
just like this this is this being that
just as a database of just gathering
stuff it's just matter of how you use it
right yeah like it's hard for me to
write love music right now cuz I'm not
in that mode like I love my fiancee but
I need her to break my heart yeah I mean
like I told algos can you just like
cheat on me real quick and then but not
really do it just say it and then I'll
write some dope-ass music just [ __ ]
do something terrible to me I can't do
that
like I love you so much did you stupid
[ __ ] let's fight let's do something
hate you you know but back in the day
she 20 she and I used to fight all just
fight all the [ __ ] time then like we
used to be at each other's throats and
now it's like in the past years why is
that my phone [ __ ] dumbass well
whatever it's okay if it goes off but if
I now we don't fight as much because
I've probably matured as a human being
we used to fight consistently I think
like every time we saw each other we
would go at it but we had turning points
in our relationship where we figured out
like yo what the [ __ ] are we fighting
about and it's the same thing that I
apply in my life that now I apply in my
relationship is I want her us to be
happy
so this petty [ __ ] doesn't matter
anymore right so why did you do this why
did you do if all I have to do is say
sorry which is very hard for me
sometimes and it alleviates the
situation just say sorry cuz even if
you're not what's the point you know
what is the [ __ ] point I mean I know
I'm very repetitive with that but that's
just how I have to view things because I
just that if my goal is to be happy and
she's not doing anything that's
fundamentally wrong like morally wrong
then what am I really fighting for at
this point she said she's crying were
fighting and nothing nothing came from
this we didn't learn from the situation
all I learned is that I'm an [ __ ] and
I I made it a point to want to make her
cry cuz I felt that she deserved to cry
which is a terrible thought to have so I
don't do that anymore
I don't I don't fight in order to win I
fight to try to prove a point to get her
to understand where I'm coming from and
once she understands then the sorry
comes
that's just my only stipulation you just
have to understand my perspective if you
understand my perspective we can
disagree on it but if you don't
understand it then we'll fight longer no
that's it that's one thing it I mean
you're talking about a romantic
relationship but that's one thing meg
and I have worked on a lot is our
communication and I feel like I'm a
fight it fight to win person and that's
been really hard for me to change that
perspective with Meg and when we talk
about our relationship a lot like that
to to make sure that what happened
before with our big breakup doesn't
happen again yeah this it's hard it's
that
saying of let's just agree to disagree
is a lot harder than people say it is
mm-hmm
it's really [ __ ] hard because you
sometimes you take it as a personal
attacks yeah well it seems like a lot of
the the arguments that we have it isn't
really so much about the thing that
we're talking about like what is gonna
be on the cover of this you know album
or something it's more just something
that kind of got off in our relationship
generally so I find that when we kind of
take a beat go do our own thing usually
have another conversation that isn't
about whatever the argument was about
about how we're feeling personally and
how we feel like with music in general
and then when we go back to that thing
it just seems so like it doesn't matter
and it's just like dad solved and it
wasn't so much about that thing - that's
awesome - it's just like now I think for
all of us is how do we get to that point
faster but that's what it always boils
down to isn't that so [ __ ] funny
though it's just yeah I don't know yeah
that just shows how dumb it was this is
dumb that's why I'm going to Hawaii
tomorrow right oh wow that's why I love
Hawaii though why do people man now give
a [ __ ] man they literally don't give a
[ __ ] come sometimes too much you know
it's like you know Fiji kids but we
Hawaiian people have this just very just
lacks thing about them like I even saw
two gut when I first came to Hawaii I
was taken to a bar there she's too big a
smoke smokes are like I don't call my
for Hawaiian hillbillies right just
country ass dudes these two mooks go at
it and they sky looks at me goes you got
beef bra which means I you want to fight
the [ __ ] he goes so [ __ ] you looking at
bro they go out like you try to scrap
you got beef raw they go outside they
start throwing down like they were
trying to murder each other the other
guy just knocked the dude on his ass it
started pounding him got up he goes you
good bro I'm good
come up cool what is that it got a drink
I was shocked I was like oh my God he's
[ __ ] grizzly bears this is this is
what they do in Hawaii but I feel like
that's their culture they have a fight
culture and once they squashed their
beef they go with it they don't Harbor
it in their hearts and they kind of move
on which is why I love going to why it
puts things in perspective for me
these people in Hawaii - there's not a
lot of job opportunity of people work
two jobs and they have a family they
have what they need they chill they
respect the land they live [ __ ] happy
and they're not rich rich except for a
few people on the island but they're
they're happy how do they figure it out
they don't have all the best nicest
[ __ ] things out there oh how do they
do it right and this city [ __ ] you up -
a lot it's a city of comparison yeah you
always look at what's what it was in
somebody else's pockets all the time in
this [ __ ] city and it's annoying
because I catch myself doing that [ __ ]
sometimes I got people don't realize
that [ __ ] I got rid of my Tesla for that
reason I got that Tesla to show people
that I had money stupid dumbest idee on
earth I hate cars cars so stupid it's
the dumbest thing I've ever invested in
it was because I wanted to say people
and I don't know if people agree with
this but I think people buy nice things
that they don't need to say look at what
I have I'm better than you
mm-hmm that's what I feel I feel like
that's what having material things are
it's a look that's why people have those
[ __ ] Kanye West t-shirts right it's a
white t-shirt and they know the only way
I would have known that this was a Kanye
West t-shirt was because you told me it
was you [ __ ] loser
it's a white t-shirt right but people
make it a point then let you know soon
enough this [ __ ] I don't care I could
really [ __ ] kill you're not gonna
take that [ __ ] with you when you die man
and I got rid of a lot of my stuff
because I was I held on to it because I
wanted to show people that yo all this
work that I did wasn't for nothing
instead of just showing and how how like
grateful I am to have these things I did
it by buying nicer things all the time
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] I Drive a Honda
Element all right now and that [ __ ] is
falling apart like consistently I think
I've honestly spent more money fixing it
than it was to buy it at this point
but it keeps me [ __ ] humble and I
love that car people think I do it as a
joke which it kind of is but at the same
time I do it because it's all I really
need until I have a kid I'll get
something a little more safe because
that [ __ ] phone well the kid I
have to care a little more about the kid
but I doubt I'll ever get a car that's
that expensive who cares it doesn't
really matter man I want people to think
that I have nothing it's the best way to
go about it maybe it's also because I
grew up in a Christian household - right
so is that whole like Jesus
Christ mentality you don't need all that
[ __ ] dude even if like people say like
I'm not a to hyper-religious which I'm
not but I still considered myself a
Christian because I still had those
great things that I learned from
Christianity I still try to apply that
in my life every day it's it's hard I
always say this the mouth of Satan the
body of Christ that's I got this dirty
[ __ ] mouth but I got the body of
Christ and then whatever happens in the
bedroom Satan comes out again but other
than that I'm Christian as [ __ ] you
stupid [ __ ] you know yeah you seem
very self aware of everything which i
think is awesome
because I feel like so many people can
just walk around not really
understanding why they do things or why
they have that car or as you were
talking about that I was thinking do I
have anything
because I wanted those those shoes with
like the heart on them do you know what
I'm talking about I'm talking about the
st. Lawrence yeah I think so yeah I know
nice things I know that they're more
expensive than a regular converse and I
mean I like cute things I like little
hearts and little faces and stuff but I
was like do I want those because they're
cool and show that I know fashion or
something or do I want them because
they're funny heart faces and I was
having that kind of thing in my head you
know I'll tell you though it's not wrong
to like nice things there's something
there's nothing wrong with it it's just
how it controls your life is what I
don't like isn't it's it's okay to have
nice things right but people always
spend more than they need then they have
to because they feel like they need to
be something than who they actually are
already if you're [ __ ] broke should
you buy like the nice [ __ ] clothes
should you probably not but in that
moment that it makes you feel good the
reason why I don't like materialism for
me and what I found out was that every
time I bought something new it had to be
replaced with something new again again
because you keep chasing that feeling
it's like the same feeling when you
gamble right people gamble because they
like that uncertainty a lot and that's
when you buy nice things it keeps you
keep trying to fill this void that you
can never fill that's why I once again
we go back to traveling the money that I
spent in traveling when I go back like I
went to Taiwan one of the best trips of
my life I go back and I think about
Taiwan again and I get happy things that
I buy
it's done for that moment I look back at
again I could give a [ __ ] less about it
but experiences memory like being
grateful for the things that you have it
gives you that same feeling all over
again and you can go back to and be
happy she was I used to buy shoes like a
[ __ ] and now specifically because
I grew up broke and I got money now so
I'm gonna get those [ __ ] shoes
you know I'll get them bought all these
shoes didn't wear anyone just had them
in these nice little cases looked into
everyday as I look everybody I got shoes
I got two feet but I got 40 shoes see
this guys this is what I have I'm a
[ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] centipede didn't I
get this why did I do this is so dumb
you know and I sold a majority of my
shoes the ones I didn't sell the ones
that were gifted to me from friends
other than that I learned I was like I
don't [ __ ] need this that's true I
just went on a trip that I felt was very
introspective and enjoyable I went to
Europe but I wonder I don't think this
is true and I wanted to ask you like if
you feel like traveling or wanting to
travel might also be kind of feeling a
void in a way to but it might be looked
at it in a slightly more acceptable form
to spend your money on I think it it it
does fill a void but it fills it at a
Statesville planning another trip yeah
it's because you can look back at those
memories and it makes you happy again
yeah I I really feel like traveling
helps me understand like the world in
general better that's whatever I consume
art especially and I think you could
keep that forever and that's the point
that I'm making it's like I can't keep
these material things forever until I
die you can but will I ever like it's
like iPhones right you get the latest
iPhone it's fun while it's here but I'm
kinda have to get the next best one and
the next one after that it doesn't
really do anything like I could care
less like I had this iPhone 8 that I got
from my friend and I'm pretty good with
it
like I don't plan to get another one
unless this one breaks you know I just I
just don't care for those things so that
I think that's the intrinsic difference
between that and then buying material
things because it fills it up and it
stays filled and it just that that that
reservoir continually gets filled and
you get to share these experiences with
people that's why I like traveling with
other friends because we get to look
back at it together we go you don't
remember that time when we did this and
you get happy
again and you want to go back to it and
it just is the gift that continually
keeps on giving because it gave me
perspective buying me something doesn't
really give me perspective unless I
[ __ ] up like the car like that gave me
great perspective haha
[ __ ] was fifteen hundred bucks a month
for that car the dumbest thing I've ever
done in my life and I was like Shh it's
a Tesla that [ __ ] gonna pay for
it so I'm paying gas not that much
dumbass
you know what idiot you know but I
didn't really think about it but I
enjoyed it for the moment and I would
learn and now I don't really care about
that stuff I'm a lot happier for it I'm
Way happier that I wasn't then when I
had that I I lost I changed my health
lost weight got rid of a lot of things
and my relationship with my fiance got
way better because I was trying to
distract myself from really fixing
myself as a human being by buying things
you know diving myself into work you
know
sounds like self-care super important I
mean I don't know if you guys want to
try this but every year at the end of
the year before it hits New Year's I go
next year's goals that are very like
just one goal that I want to achieve in
the next year and I look back at
everything that I've done this year and
I say bro you did a good job that's what
I do helps me out a lot
I'm like a man you did this and if you
didn't do as much as you thought you
could then you take that and you bring
it on to next year hmm it helps out a
lot that's what I always do that every
[ __ ] year and I don't know when I
started that [ __ ] but it it was a while
back it was definitely before I moved to
LA and I used to write it in a little
book and [ __ ] because I thought I was
[ __ ] tiles like man everybody doing
this job writing books - homie do you
remember what your goal was for every
[ __ ] year was to lose weight and it
took 30 years yeah [ __ ] hey Ben
finally it's checked off I'm like oh
it's God yeah we do that as sisters when
we go hiking that's do we have this
ritual where we'll get to the end of the
hike and then we'll say alright
everybody what's your goal for the next
it's usually like for the next time we
see each other which will be either like
a season or a year sometimes or a half a
year and this last time we went my goal
was to do solo traveling and I did my
goal and went solo traveling kind of for
the first time and it did feel good to
say
what were you going I don't know I think
I said something like this and then they
said yeah you did say that and you did
it by all and it feels [ __ ] good yeah
I think the the the the overarching
topic of this is being grateful but I I
feel like I really I really needed this
talk today so I'm gonna carry this with
me yeah one word I'm telling you man le
[ __ ] you up though like I I really
really [ __ ] does is it's hard to get
away from it it really is David
sometimes it's like 2:00 in the morning
I'm down some rabbit hole of an
Instagram looking at like a supermodel
who's like 19 years old who has six
packs on her arms and I'm just like why
why am i and then all of a sudden I'm
like I'm crazy it's 2:00 a.m. oh is this
how do I even get here
why yeah or you could do what I do which
is very unhealthy but it helps me out
I'm like her parents probably beat her
though whatever I start creating like
these backstories that don't exist my
parents don't love her whatever [ __ ]
whatever I got whatever do she probably
go blind in ten years I feel a lot
better it's a Korean thing though it's
called Han we have Han did and I just
it's like this vengeance type of thing
and I'm like yeah that's how goo started
to us to be honest with you people
wouldn't cast me for any for [ __ ] they
wouldn't like casting [ __ ] agents
wouldn't sign me
it's aford like digital media they
wouldn't send me out to auditions I'm
like okay I'll do my own [ __ ] filming
[ __ ] you okay and then lo and behold it
happened it happened a lot faster than I
thought it would but it happened that's
I don't know I'm maybe I'm a little
weird like that but I like how you just
did that then you just did this amazing
film because most people's first films I
did a horror film that you will never
see that believed made like this weird
me where like my arm like prosthetic arm
comes out this like 1/4 the size of what
my regular being just like kind of
explodes but like everybody has those
weird awkward first movie moments it was
just like this Sundance darling
best performance ever incredible story I
linked that with the right people to I
mean Justin killed it you know that's
all Justin right there I'm I just
brought in my perspective and then my
life story to it and then kind of
bring life into it for my character and
you know like the black perspective but
yeah I just that's why I'm saying like
even that that's what I'm so I'm like
damn I can't believe I [ __ ] did that
that's crazy to me yeah I can't believe
I even got to go to some I didn't even
know what really how big Sundance was
until I went to Sundance right and then
I was like oh [ __ ] I see these people in
movies like what are they doing here
like dude Sundance is a [ __ ] big deal
David and I'm like oh but you know even
with that too it harbored a lot of weird
feelings for him from other friends who
are actors right not my good friends but
they're like oh you got Sundance this
thing do better [ __ ] I don't know what
to tell you okay suck my [ __ ] nuts
because I shouldn't have to feel bad for
my accomplishes because you feel bad - I
gotta feel bad it's not like I'm really
doing anything with it I think that even
pisses them off even more they're like
whoa why don't you go on more auditions
who said I wanted to be either the best
actor on earth I never said that
I just said I wanted to go into Sundance
and I wanted to make a film I did what I
wanted to do you can't tell me to be
happy with your [ __ ] goals I hit my
goal you know people are kind of weird
like that and like I said at least we're
beasts it is that weird thing of of you
know if somebody does it younger if they
do it faster so my friend was telling me
that somebody just moved from like the
Midwest and they were kind of asking
about how to get into acting and then a
month later they booked a series regular
and and you know we're on like our 300th
audition our 300th know and there is a
piece of me that's like but there's the
other side it's like they were the right
person for the job it's not my time
right now and in a big lesson that I had
to learn was that when somebody gets
something they're not taking it from me
exactly they're just we're all riding
this way together and a win for one
person is a win for all of us were all
like raising the tide and that was a big
mentality shame that's real posit I
don't even do that so that was a lot of
just do this cycle damn they got some
terrible taste all right on to the next
one you know I don't even go that far
you're really positive I'm just like
damn they got Pig
[ __ ] suck yeah I'm like dude what am
I gonna get then I'll get something
better right because that person's hot
[ __ ] trash so I don't know my
positive in a different positive way
though I still gotta talk my [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know oh la dude I'm tell you la
la whatever whenever I visit her in Utah
I'm like oh it's more intense but I mean
la is more intense than you top but Utah
still has its thing like Utah is um Salt
Lake City is a very small community yeah
so we're still comparing like who did
what not and who's with so-and-so and
who's well it's not a different scale I
guess it is it is Martinez
I think it's harder for a lot of women
just because I've seen I almost don't
see women with lip injections and
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] here and here now
it's like whose faces they're face
anymore man like what what's wrong what
was wrong with your face before you were
completely fine you were beautiful the
way that you were but you got it in your
[ __ ] head from going on Instagram is
seeing these other girls and you see
their [ __ ] likes and you wanted to be
like them because they got attention and
now you [ __ ] up your [ __ ] face
because you couldn't appreciate what you
had and it's terrible I [ __ ] hate it
with everything that I [ __ ] Hannah
that's the thing about Korea too is I
hate this yeah I'm not sure if this is
still accurate but I heard that Korea
South Korea was the number one place in
the world for plastic surgery especially
the eyelid surgery yeah wait Jeep went
to whatever whenever I go to Seoul I
just think everybody looks so pretty and
unique and like I didn't get Korean eyes
and I you know you always want what you
can't have but I think they're so pretty
and they're trying to fix what I think
is beautiful and it's all that weird
yeah you know yeah I just I just don't
like that I just I think it's a weird
shift you'll see it in tweets too
because before the shift was before the
the conversation was appreciate what you
have loved yourself right now the thing
is well if it's my body why can't I
change it why do you care that's the
that's the rhetoric now I'm like what
the [ __ ] happened dude what what what
[ __ ] happening all see my nose job I
don't give a [ __ ] what y'all think I'm
beautiful
thirty thousand [ __ ] likes it's like
no you do care what people think because
you changed your [ __ ] nose so you do
some now some of them mind you have some
[ __ ] up knows it so I'm like you
probably needed it but there's some
people got some regular last noses and
they just want it to be more Western or
something or some [ __ ] cuz I saw one
girl her nose look like a [ __ ] what
do you call like a habanero pepper that
she look [ __ ] up but when she changed
it it was a good thing for her like I
look terrible but the other people too
they just don't need to and I don't I
don't understand I guess that's it
shouldn't be my place to tell somebody
what they need or what they don't need
but you're gonna age things are gonna
happen when you get old nobody give a
[ __ ] about what you look like
right I've never looked at the 7 year
old woman and be like what the [ __ ] you
look I'm not being a mess [ __ ] I'm just
saying this an old lady and I'm pretty
sure that she lived a very fulfilling
life without it and I think that
changing your physical appearance and
doing all these like cosmetic surgeries
I think you're really trying to cover up
and insecurity that you have that can't
be fixed with a knife that's my that's
my [ __ ] because a lot of the people that
I know that do that they constantly want
to fix something else oh I don't like
this oh I don't like this I have this I
don't like this it's like it's never
[ __ ] ending it's never ending you
will always scrutinize yourself for
every day for the rest of your life
whether you think is fixed because the
moment you fix that you know something
else is wrong oh this eyes a little
smaller than the other one it's like God
dude it's always like the prettiest
girls that I know - the ones that are
the most beautiful I may scrutinize
everything about their face and I'm like
girls would kill to look like you did
they would kill to look like you and you
don't even appreciate what you had so
[ __ ] sad dude yeah
well guys that was an hour 30 minutes in
this is like a 45 minute podcast I was
great you know what I usually get other
people to cry you made me cry and he saw
me these [ __ ] they're like dah
somebody got David this was supposed to
be a comedy podcast originally and it
turns out I'm just the pastor so I
didn't realize that we get real deep in
here because it starts really fun and
light and then it's like oh man there's
some deep [ __ ] probably talking about I
swear I think I think about eight or
nine people cried on this podcast and I
don't know what it is but y'all some
hurt human beings
I love you guys well guys that wraps up
this episode of the genius brain podcast
plug everything that you guys want to
plug OH
our new record it's called happy sad
we're on tour we're Megan dia check them
out amazing musicians super great guest
you guys can catch the genius brain
podcast on every audio platform out
there if you're on the iTunes podcast
give us that five star I love you stupid
stupid sons of [ __ ] be grateful for
what you had because if you don't I will
take everything from you I [ __ ] love
you bye